thank you for joining us America Anthony
is with us in New York hi Anthony
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
how are you better than I deserve
what's up I was just wondering what your
game plan would be for my situation I
turning 25 in a couple of months Tuesday
I start my new job I'm going from $11 an
hour part-time to making sixty seven
thousand a year good for you thank you
how old are you turning 25 in two months
okay good for you very cool what are you
gonna be doing for a living computer
science programming good good excellent
cool and right now I'm still living with
my parents which is the I know at this
age you would have probably kicked your
kids out that's probably trauma but
you're doing good man yeah you got your
now you got the money to go right yeah
okay you know I have sixty five hundred
and three ones and two thousand and
credit the LinkedIn your salary that
should be no problem yeah you gotta be
able plow through those while you're
living in a nice apartment a decent
apartment somewhere yeah that that's
what I was wondering is you should I
save up should I stay a little longer
and save up for a down payment for a
house or should I just get out and get
my apartment I'm gonna park I'd get an
apartment get out of debt build your
emergency fund then save up for a down
payment on the house okay yeah your life
your life will change for the better
when you get out on your own yeah under
the roof a little too long yeah it
changes the way you walk dude changes
everything it's just you know obviously
you have a great relationship with your
parents and they don't mind you being
there I was that way with one of ours
one of ours came home after college and
she stayed with us about three or four
months and honestly kids a joy I
wouldn't have been any problem at all
for her to stay and we had plenty of
room and didn't bother us a bit but you
know it was really really good for her
when she left right I think that's my
situation now I'm paying around my pain
I pay for everything on my own except
for food yeah you don't have to hate
your parents to leave I mean it's not
required
yeah
some people have to get a house you know
but in your case you were blessed like
my daughter and you know we enjoyed
having her around she enjoyed being
there but it's just good for her to have
her own deal and and it it you will look
back on that as a part of your you know
part of your 20s that it was a blessing
that they gave you a place there for a
while and you got a good foundation
under you make that huge jump from the
part-time job into the into a major job
and hey congratulations I'm very proud
of you but yeah I would just get on out
get you a decent place maybe get your
room mate or something keep your costs
down and knock out the knock out the
debts and build your emergency fund and
build up a down payment for a house and
obviously you'll be able to do that and
you got a great career field that you're
in so you're probably gonna end up
making more and more and more money as
you go along as you get some experience
to go with the degree and so forth hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind